I want you to call my back to this do
you remember we went outside and we had
a go with this thing and after we
started to think about how this would
connect to calculus are the kinds of
insights we could gain from it right so
just to revise what we did was we came
up with a displacement equation we
guessed at one based on the sort of flat
path of the ball and how it went with
respect to time money now we we looked
at this and we recognize it looks like a
parabola
and when you you consider over time it
looked like a concave down problem so
off that we differentiated to get a
velocity function right so that's DX DT
you call it V if you like because
velocity right and then we went one more
time to think about acceleration which
by the way we I drew attention to the
fact that the units for these are it is
one length unit one distance here and
there's two time units which is why you
get meters per second per second right
alternatively even though I wouldn't
exactly recommend it you could write
this I suppose like this I mean that's
the way we write meters per second per
second and as I use it index of minus
two right but anyway we could also
indicate that by just calling an A for
acceleration now that was the way wet
even that order we started from
displacement it's differentiated to get
to velocity and then we differentiate
begin to get to acceleration but then
you might have noticed if you remember
we ended up with a problem because we
basically made up this equation right
what we ended up getting to at the
bottom actually wasn't it didn't gel
with reality because we got a number
there do you remember what it was I
think it was something like negative
three something like that okay now we
knew is negative that was good because
the ball dropped down to the ground but
we knew that this number was wrong
because we know what this number is
supposed to be it represents something
we're familiar with namely gravity right
so gravity is not near three we have it
approximate
gravity and that's gonna be our starting
point for today because the point is
that you don't necessarily have to go
downward differentiate through your
motion equations you can go in the other
direction because we know how to do that
so long as you have enough information
okay so make a little summary which is
starting with gravity okay so here's
what we're going to do instead of
conjuring up a displacement equation
right and then climbing down the ladder
we're going to start with something we
can empirically confirm which is we
actually know what the force of gravity
is okay now questions should be nice and
they should say assume and then they'll
talk about the force of gravity right
and you're either this sort of to many
classes there's going to be extracting
that back this three sometimes they'll
just say call it G all right
and so you'll just have that letter
floating around in your equations it's a
cluster you don't really have to worry
about it alternatively they'll give you
one of two values for G okay the common
ones are 10 as in 10 meters per second
per second or the other ones 9.8 okay my
point it's a bit more of it's a bit more
accurate so I'm gonna go with that okay
now they can assume that's the
acceleration with relationship to
gravity but of course it's going down
with right now they'll often say it like
this and they won't tell you which way
to go the reason why they're doing that
is because they're giving you
flexibility as to choose whether X
positive is up or X positive is down
okay and depending on which direction
you choose for the question that'll
determine the direction that gravity is
going okay so for now let's just go with
gravity being negative okay so I can say
therefore neglecting air resistance not
thinking about the fact that the bigger
this object is that effects
it's acceleration and velocity and so on
I can say the only thing that's
accelerating this object will wear
another way he's grabbing that's all
okay
so I can say X double dot right our
acceleration I'm gonna say it's negative
9.8 so I'm considering X positive as up
that makes gravity go down common sense
okay from there since I'm starting here
if I want to go upwards of those things
about loss in displacement I need to
integrate right so I could say
integrating I get X dot and think about
this I'm integrating with respect to
well these are all functions of time
aren't they right you can tell by the
you can tell by the T's okay we can
express them in terms of other things
but we'll get onto that later if I
integrate with respect to time
and this is what I'm signing with what
will I get for my velocity equation
minus that point eight and I'll just be
multiplied by T what a lot of it okay
that's good but there's something else I
have to account for this is an
indefinite integral other boundaries
right so I need a constant now I'm
actually gonna call it cuz I know I'm
gonna get another one in a second I'm
gonna call it close to one because I
don't want to have to see splitting
rather actually equal to nothing okay
now I can integrate one more time to get
to a displacement equation now the
interesting thing about this one cycle
the dots just acts the interesting thing
about this is once I get to this result
these three equations these three motion
equation will tell me what happens all
the time when you're only acceleration
is due to gravity all the time no matter
how you start but you'll see why in a
second okay so let's iterate negative
9.8 it's gonna turn into negative four
point nine right because the powers gone
up by one and then yet to divide by the
power okay so you're gonna get very
familiar with seeing these over and over
again because they always come up when
you have gravity right okay you've got a
cluster flying off on the answer you're
going to get a tea along with you
and then of course because we've
integrated a second time you have a
second constant
okay there you go so generally speaking
these are the three equations that you
get and you always get if you start with
gravity okay so you can put in different
kinds of conditions into this to start
to evaluate your constants and we
usually evaluate them as we go okay so
let's go and think back about the tennis
ball okay so little sub example
we'll come back to this idea right now
if we start with gravity right I'm going
to go here this is my starting point
okay so I need to grate up what
but I actually know some things about
how what we did with the test ball right
so frizzes I mean I threw it straight up
in the air okay now in order to work out
this constant to evaluate it okay I need
some condition between time and X dot
velocity right so in other words I need
to know at some point in time how fast
was the ball going is that make sense
today for some value of T I need to know
velocity so you've got some choices okay
the most common one is you get initial
conditions okay so suppose an initial
condition
now initial obviously it implies T
equals zero right what do you think
might be a reasonable guess for how hard
I threw the ball if I throw a ball how
far is it going to travel it's a you
know one second this is hot I mean it's
hard to measure because it all happens
pretty quickly
I'm going to say four is this 15 meters
are sent here upward I don't think
that's unusual 15 meters is actually not
that far I'm walking travel pretty fast
15 minutes later on we'll be able to
test just like we did here you know this
is wrong we'll be able to test out the
accuracy of these numbers in a second
because we'll see what we get for
displacement the station points and so
on okay so let's just give that a go if
that's true I can sub that in here right
so I can say of when T equals zero X dot
should equal 15 right that makes sense
so I stopped it in the way that I
usually do
I'll get 15 over here minus zero plus my
constant and of course as you'd expect
right and as will happen again your time
terms just disappear and you're just
left with the constant so you'll get
used to that klutz that's simply being
equal to your initial condition
which I suppose would correspond to the
fact that this is you know whining was
MX plus B type thing this is the
y-intercept that's the initial condition
okay great now I have a velocity
equation
I'll integrate again to give me a
displacement equation which needs me yes
whoops sorry
and again I'll need some kind of values
some kind of point in time and a
displacement that I know so that I can
actually evaluate this constant okay
now let's actually push on this a little
bit before we had a bit of a simplified
model and we called my hand the origin
and I I caught the ball okay let's just
make things a little more interesting
suppose I threw the ball up from that
position but I didn't catch it
that's a more interesting kind of
situation to deal with more thing so
therefore when time equals zero you know
suppose an initial condition I've got a
couple of choices right I could keep one
calling my hand the origin right
that would mean when he hits the ground
what would that beating back to space
minute it would be negative cuz it's
below my hand okay alternatively I could
call something else the origin what else
might we choose I could choose the
ground as the origin which would be at
time zero where is the ball I mean well
however high it is right now let's see
actually you know so that's not a bad
starting point
why would call it Emil that's kind of
convenient okay so now I have when time
0 suppose addition addition of 1 meter
above the ground that's where I throw
the ball from ok so I'm going to get
this time step again when T equals 0 X
displacement you can see what's gonna
happen the same kind of thing because
it's an initial condition this time term
and this time term will disappear so you
can say that constant hanging off on the
end that's going to be equal to 1 so now
I have my displacement equation
okay cool why we test this out and see
how reasonable it was okay I want to get
you in a few minutes
to draw this and to put some questions
to it okay so here's what I want you
draw and I'm not going to tell you what
questions to post on I just want you to
think what can I gain from this what
kind of useful information can I
interpret off this once i graph it okay
so make your scale sort of decent still
you can see things you're going to have
some weed decimals in there maybe you
need to saw so you can actually get some
values in here they're awkward numbers
but that's okay you can still work with
them with the quadratic formula give
that a go